[Music]
oh
oh baby welcome back to the break room
it's tuesday so good to see you breakers
your roomies your super trash uh we're
so glad to have you back here on the
break room live from our very own break
room here at new rockstars hq at an
undisclosed location that you will never
find uh this is that daily show we do
where we talk about all the geek news
that's good for you good for me good for
all of us and coming up today we have
spiderman villain updates
we got a kenobi finale coming this
evening along with another episode of
miss marvel along with umbrella academy
it's all happening tonight
uh we're gonna make our finale
predictions for kenobi uh and we got so
much more to talk about we got to get
into it uh you know me my name is
brandon i'm i'm the old og uh but
hanging out with me today we got jessica
clemens i'm completely in the middle
this time completely in the middle
meet her in the middle meet me in the
middle uh we also have tommy bechdol so
great to be back you guys another
tuesday we're lucky to be alive i woke
up with a smile on my face and now i'm
happy to be in this place with all of
you that's right there's only three of
us today but don't count us out because
with three
it's better it's a magic number it's a
magic number it's a magic number it
takes three to make a thing go right
perfect um we have our reverse swear jar
going today as part of our chat
redemptions what's the reverse swear jar
you're asking to your computer screen by
yourself uh we're not allowed to curse
on this show it's forbidden philip says
no uh but if we raise a hundred dollars
in super chats we will open up the swear
jar and let out a few swears and then if
we get the 200 in this little square jar
who knows where we could go
it builds from there uh but before we
even get started we got to address
a super chat that came in just last
minute yesterday we gotta address the
super chat in the room the super chat in
the room i know you guys have seen it
you've asked about it we gotta talk
about it uh jordan holland he sent a
great super chat right at the end and he
had a special request but i think we
should fulfill yes uh he said love your
hair jessica
which just was yesterday's hair but
today yesterday's hair was like witchy
hair today's hair is riva hair
repair in honor of the queen but he did
ask you to curse curse us out he said i
don't know if that was the royal us i
don't know if he's got a mouse in his
pocket
oh i hope he does oh i hope he does do
you want to give him a little taste of
what the swear joker oh this is what a
taste of the swear jar will look like
jordan holland in the chat thank you for
saying you like my hair you
[ __ ] sim
[ __ ] baby
congrats you're the one chosen to get
leashed yeah walk down the street by
yours truly jessica oh my god you're
gonna be my little [ __ ] today oh baby
oh my god step on our neck that's what
it's all about
if you want more of that action you know
what to do throw in those super chats
ammo already formally submitting himself
for number four i don't think so maybe
maybe we'll consider it uh and ernest
esteban saying three's company that's
right come on knock on our doors yes
this is like this is like a reboot of
three's company right yeah we have a
lady and then two dudes you're
[Music]
hundred percent perfect perfect um
we got a lot to talk about today let's
get into it with the headlines
oh he got back there in time thank god
dasher i really you were running out of
time
nearly
missed that switch but he got it he got
what a great job uh our first headline
today spider-man star jacob battle on
has added fuel to the fire that his
character ned may one day become
hobgoblin by posting this picture to his
instagram story look at that damning
evidence the old hobgoblin i mean i
think ever since they you know it was
kind of revealed that spider-man's best
friend loves to try and kill him all the
time mm-hmm i think he's gonna be there
is a comic story line when that becomes
hobgoblin briefly right i believe so
yeah so
uh that's me that's the old tommy
bechtold source of information i
speculate on something look to one of my
co-hosts don't ever guarantee that it's
true and then walk away yeah that's i
just blindly agree with you yeah i
appreciate it i feel like i blindly
agreed to which i think is a problem we
love it if we're wrong put it in the
chat and we won't even address it yeah
we'll ignore you trash bag
next headline baby
uh we got a new stranger things season
four part two lots of numbers uh they
got a new trailer out today uh the
second part it looks pretty crazy looks
going over the top
is someone gonna die is someone finally
gonna die on the show also someone
important gonna die on this show yes the
line in the trailer where i think it's
back into speaking and he's just like
you've seen enough like now just watch
yeah just like watching him
watch i think he's talking to nancy i
think he's talking to nancy and nancy's
gonna die you think he's gonna make but
is dancing gonna die but like keep her
alive in the upside down as like his
queen or something like that no i think
he's a dog queen so that would be fun
sorry no no you're good i don't i'm like
i don't want him to find love period
because everyone deserves a lot
even old ancient monsters
i don't think he's an old ancient
monster i think he's this the worst
version of uh
number one
yeah and well we don't know he could be
like that it could have fast forward his
timeline it could be he could have been
around but i don't like that he looks
inside out
like inside out boy
and but also um i think he's gonna nancy
is traumatized and i think nancy could
be one of the victims for him and he's
like i was gonna choose you but i chose
max because she's worse and i want you
to watch all your friends die and then
i'll kill you but then he's gonna kill
him listen i was watching a lot of stuff
that happened to you a bear and a lot of
red flags for me i've had some bad
relationships in the past i'm not ready
to get hurt again seems like you have a
lot of baggage now i like him
if i only could i'd make a deal with god
uh i think uh i think that that nancy
nancy's a good guess i also think
jonathan
is a is a potential but i say he's a
dark horse let's not throw out uh winona
ryder's character oh you think an adult
why not joyce think about it that sets
up in the final season jonathan and will
avenging their mother's death at the
hands of the mind flayer or possibly you
know
you know going back to where it's all
started not that i want joyce to die
because i want her and hopper to end up
happily ever after but i just think you
know of the adults they're not gonna
they're not gonna kill hopper after all
of this right like that would be it
would be after like fake killing they're
gonna
uh kill the guy whatever uh what's his
name with the glasses oh yeah yeah yeah
i'm still gonna be like this isn't
enough for me
yeah kill nancy yeah i mean you got to
kill a kid let's see a kid die please i
shot a kid i have to ask this every day
with every movie i see let's kill a kid
come on hey i've been banking on
spider-man dying soon earlier and i'm
still riding when he dies finally you
guys can yell at me take your anger out
on me but he is going to die jessica
i don't feel so good
oh no that died not that one
i i was pretty sad when peter b or peter
parker died in uh across the spider
versus
very traumatizing yeah um it's very sad
plus i love chris who voiced yeah that
was christian baby chris pine he also
sing this song uh
spider bells spider bells
are you making it up no it's in the
movie and you can get it on that you can
check it out on spotify all the
spider-man christmas songs they're great
next headline hey
looks like meets back on the menu boys
as we got our first look at the orcs in
amazon's upcoming lord of the rings
series let's take a look at these orgy
boys oh
look at these pieces oh so speaking of
weakness yeah that is an inside out
person an ashy inside out person i like
how they're a little like thinner yeah
you know i think yeah
you know my lord of the rings knowledge
is a little light apologies to the jet
uh but they're like made out of the
earth right they just kind of like yes
they're like gollums almost like they
just make them out of the earth yeah and
they're like a factory they're forged
deep in the orc forge yeah why'd you say
dashiell
oh that's the urukai my apology will
come run out into one of our microphones
and tell us the 4-1-1 on this show i'm
getting my er guys and my orcs as long
as if i will only watch this show and
you guys have to tell me if an end shows
up because if the ants don't oh there's
gotta be then i'm not watching it how
could they do this whole show take those
long movies stretch it out even more and
not put the answers there's gotta be an
idea are you guys gonna i think we're
already doing a poll are you guys gonna
watch the new lord of the rings show yes
yes answer yes can we do a quick poll if
they're gonna ask i'm only gonna watch
you guys
i'll be honest i saw her over this orc
discourse about the org for jim for
lauren
say one more time
i said i sour over this orc discourse
about the orc forge i'm poor lauren he's
eminem over there uh i stumbled on that
hey we did run a poll earlier if people
would like to see ned become a villain
and 57 of you said yes yes i think it's
a good storyline uh especially
i mean it seems easier now that he
doesn't know who spider-man is yeah yeah
much easier to get there i i do like it
in a world where he knows exactly who
spider-man is and something just pushes
him over the edge oh that's great he has
an obsession with matt because he loves
peter right you know or loved before
r.i.p to his memories uh don't we wish
we could all wipe our memories away
there'd be so many years i'd take away
if i could like it would every
embarrassing moment that i twitch about
and think about like 30 years is like
that would all be taken like the time i
tripped in high school i tripped in high
school threw my pizza into the senior
girl's face and she was the popular girl
and then ever since then it would matter
she deserved it you know she deserved it
marley was nice we we
my friends and i used to think we were
backstreet boys in high school and we
would sing and like we would serenade
girls which i'm sure they hated and
would be very problematic now and one
time in the party uh at a party we were
arguing over who was sue and i kept
yelling i'm the high man i'm the high
man but it's not like i was yelling i'm
the hymen and everybody just started
chanting you're the hymen at me you're
like snip snip get that memory out yeah
so i'd like that gone
uh i have no bad memories and i was
super cool in high school and everyone
loved me uh another friend that killed
his mom i don't want to talk about that
not wait didn't you just
it seems like 61 of you are going to
watch the new lord of the rings series
which we love to hear and we won't be
covering it on this channel 61 that's a
lot yeah okay i'll watch it just because
you guys recommended it
always watch it rather than read the
books because reading is hard and i
don't like it reading is for suckers
it's a waste of time remember that the
break room does not endorse reading big
literature is making you think that
reading is important but it's really not
and what about all those trees yeah what
about all those do you think they like
being chopped down i read digital books
on my ipad are you saying that to the
fbi what's happening here they cut they
cut down trees to fuel the ipads oh no
i forgot uh
we got a kenobi finale tonight
i had a connection about it
let's talk about our kenobi predictions
this is the final episode of the much
beloved obi-wan kenobi series that has
just been flying through its story uh
you know with a story like this where we
know so many of the characters
have this
the strong plot armor of like we know
that they're alive in 10 more years so
they can't die uh we know that none of
that's gonna happen so rather than
making just like blank blanket
predictions i'm going to uh offer up
some like what's more likely to happen
scenarios oh let's talk through them
okay uh my first one for for my esteemed
panel is
what's more likely riva dies
for real this time or
riva turns to the light side of the
force and redeems herself
she could still die in that scenario but
what's more likely she just straight up
dies gets slaughtered she's the big bad
because we can't kill vader can we
choose the in between i still i don't
think she dies but i think she's not
going to join the light side but you
think she's going to protect
luke in some way or like turn against
vader again she's still just trying to
go after vader i think her she's like a
horse with blinders her mission is this
she's going after that mission she
doesn't care about the others unless
it's obi-wan because obi-wan didn't help
so i think she's still going to survive
i just think she's going to be so
stricken with like i don't like
i have one mission and this is my one
mission that maybe that eats her alive
i think she's gonna die i don't yeah i
don't want her to i like that character
i think there's more interesting
pathways that could go with her showing
her life beyond this failure but still
being you know being able to use the
force but she shouldn't kill darth vader
so what's next do you continue this like
quixote and quest
like you keep chasing the windmills
trying uh to kill darth vader or do you
realize like i'm pretty powerful i can
either become a crime lord or a
mercenary or an angel of vengeance for
other people you know i mean she could
pull on ahsoka right and just like
reject all of that right and go lone
wolf and do whatever she wants it's so
interesting to see her do the do that
way i'm not gonna even try saying her
name because you guys yell at me when i
try to say
her name i think i say it wrong
everybody i say it wrong every time but
i'm saying really fast at the same time
[Laughter]
ahsoka
um actually so i think it's hard to read
i don't know maybe it's because we see
her and she still has so much respect
versus what reva has so it's like i'm
like i still think you it's that balance
is not there okay i think she still has
too much hate in her heart to like
be able to balance it i think she's
gonna die but i think they're gonna
redeem her is there a way for this to
end good i mean it we know how it's
gonna end but yeah i guess the
characters that aren't along the lines
of the star wars franchise like they
could still have bad or good endings
right i mean you know hajja could die or
uh
that little o'shea jackson oh sorry
jackson could die quinlan boss could
show up and be like howdy folks
again i don't know kill himself i don't
know uh lots of good answers in the chat
a lot of people saying riva turned to
the light side riva dying i think i
think we're kind of like
uh a little mixed into here in between
here sorry the chad said jessica you can
never pronounce anyone's name ouch chat
out how dare you
how dare you chad batch so also the
people in the chat keep asking about
zach and i got to say yesterday he took
his anger towards the transformers and
i'm not talking about the autobots or
decepticons i mean the physical
electric transformers he's out in
bakersfield just lashing out yeah we
thought it would slow him down but the
electrical force has only made him
stronger it's only made him stronger
okay what's more likely to happen okay
we have uh
uh
what's more likely to happen obi-wan
interacts with a young luke cause i
don't think they've interacted yet at
all or
owen lars goes medieval protecting the
homestead and really shows what he can
do and lights some people up i think
it's a twofer okay i think owen lars
goes medieval and i think aunt peru goes
with
uh ass kicking kind of a little
redemption for them yeah yeah and i also
think like i mean luke knows who kenobi
is in the new hope so like they they've
met before i think but i don't think
that that interaction is as important
well he he kind of talks like that guy
over there like he knows who he is in
the town but i don't think that they
were like best best talking and hanging
out he tried to leave him little
trinkets you know and owen was like you
ain't no santa claus yeah do you think
that that little uh t16 left if you they
planted it in the ground and watered it
and it grew into the big t-60 yes that's
all right
exactly what do you think jessica what's
more likely to happen i think it's gonna
be the first one obi-wan interacts with
luke but i wanted to be the second one i
wanted to be a second one i just think
there's too much going on right now i
won't cry if they if they interact but
the second he talked away i started
crying it was tragic terrible we did ask
the chat about our first what's more
likely to happen 64 percent think it's
more likely for riva to die than to turn
to the light side of the forest they're
on my side
i think that's fair do we will we be sad
when she dies
because we didn't that's why i don't
think she's gonna die because we don't
have that attachment yet because i'm
attracted but i think i think it's like
me too i think you know you've had like
uh obi-wan and vader battle
and maybe they'll battle again i hope
they battle again but like none of them
can win that fight like you need if we
want to if we want oh we want to get the
real w and take someone out besides just
some storm troopers who's chopping up
it's got to be a riva right he's going
to take down
i need them i need obi-wan and vader to
have a better fight
i want that i think i think we're going
to have to have a better form and i
don't want reba to intervene no i don't
know that's what i'm irritated i'm like
i'm like reba you better be out on the
ground when they get to wow that is a
close oh zach hudson hiding in the chat
if you're looking prediction grand
inquisitor shows up at avengercon oh
zach aren't you beating trucks right now
electricity from yeah he must have
gotten some rc cars last night he's got
their battery powers uh in the chat
you're pretty split in the chat 50
obi-wan interacts with luke 49 owen bars
goes medieval i don't know where that
other one percent is hiding but we will
find it yeah uh we always lose that one
but i i i don't ever want to forget it i
don't want to forget it also also i i
need obi-wan to chop uh vader's helmet
off to expose uh
young scarred vader oh
i've been predicting that all season i
need it to happen
to happen tonight
okay what's more likely to happen
cameo wise
we get a grogu cameo or
we have a calcus game
what's more likely to happen definitely
not grosgu no girl girl
no he's in too
they're moving stuff around in the shed
and they're like what's this thing and
they just throw the egg and the woods
imply these things oh so we're just
assuming that yeah yeah yeah so show me
the baby um no i i would lean more
calcul if i have kelly says if i don't
okay what do you say tommy i think
neither i think we're gonna get it
max revo cameo oh my gosh no i think
everybody in the chat wants that
calculator
yeah
i i also would like to see
this or at least something that links
the games to this kenobi story you know
like i mean i think you don't think uh
uh kenobi speed running that level yeah
at the inquisitor's inquisitors
i needed him to connect a few more uh
uh cables together everyone was like i
know how to do this i played the game
yeah and he's like
the boy has got to be trained
like you trained his father
from the people is
someone that can write a rap song right
now for us and put it on soundcloud and
do the intro which is that oh yeah that
is a good intro
chat wants that calculus 72 percent i
believe
right and all of a sudden the little
ghost shows up and quite gone is like
what the hell was that yeah what are you
wrong
asking for you to show up this entire
time this is when you pull up sorry i
was busy being a ghost
having relationships i said kill rebo
not reba what you get a reboot i said
killing rebirth
okay finally what's more likely to
happen
luke uses the force or
hajja uses the force
[Applause]
what more likely is [ __ ] uses the force
what's more likely than all of this is
none of it happens
okay none of that happened okay
does haja have the force i keep i can't
tell i know he was faking it before but
is he are they trying to set up that
like no the force is inside he actually
is if he ends up having the force
i will punch my tv i think i think uh
hajj is going to wind up uh using the
force impressing like a female jedi he
runs across they get married they make
love they have a child
and then they sell the child to that
casino and that's the child with the
broom
yeah we actually don't want a kid we're
going to sell this yes that's going to
those lines is him like hitting on
someone or tricking someone and then
something actually does move with the
force and he's like what and he looks
back and it's kano be like
i got you buddy
steal from these bubbles
that would be funny that would be fun
thinks he's using the force uh you guys
had some great uh questions and
predictions of your own and some of the
super chats jay master saying obi-wan
kenobi finale prediction darth vader
will find out about luke in tattooween
but not find out about leia
it's possibility possible that retcon's
a little bit
of the comics maybe
unless he's just like finds out and he's
like i don't care i don't know adam in
the chat um
said if darth vader doesn't go ham and
kill some innocent people i'm going to
be disappointed and i agree with you
holy he already killed some minutes when
he snapped that man's neck i jumped from
my seat and said my
my my lord my lord my lord i was so i
was so into it it was so horrible i
loved it my lord
richard richard lyle's also asking do
you think riva is finn's mother or
grandmother are they going to tie in
riva to finn smith you know i i i don't
know that we're gonna like
riva that implies a whole other like
story where riva meets a man gets
pregnant and then they both die and the
kid gets kidnapped gets conscripted
there's only uh three black people in
this galaxy
well i mean we all saw like
we all saw rise of skywalker we're like
lando's definitely that one black girl's
dad
it's gotta be the math is all there you
don't understand fire
shows up again gets stabbed again yeah
not dead orlando's just flying by yeah
he's like well hello there well
well well uh i think the funny thing is
like according to like
the star wars family trees it's like all
of these huge convoluted relations and
then all the black characters just one
straight system one straight line that's
not right
super chatting oh boy zach huddleston
going crazy in the super chats can i get
an r2 from jessica a watto from brandon
and a brody stevens from tommy
is that asking too much i'll do i'll do
the watto yes
here we'll use the a representation i
guess you don't remember what what it
looks
like amy
would you want to do this
your republic credits are no good here
you like magics don't work on me
[Music]
that was too good um i haven't done it
in a minute yeah are you ready i think
so
oh
yes
still got it she's still got it she's
still got it enjoy it push and believe
eight one eight till i die
beautiful beautiful stuff beautiful
stuff killing them killing them in the
chat they love it they love it so much
positive energy um push and believe yeah
and our final question that we had uh
you guys in the chat think 60 percent of
you think we'll see luke use the force
even if he's not aware of what the force
is obviously but like yeah he might do
something i i i don't know it would be
interesting to see yeah i don't know do
you think vader's gonna show up on
tatooine i just don't want it doesn't
really
[Music]
i think well yeah but i mean you don't
want it to but it is it like a i don't
want it to in a good way or yeah for a
story reason
no i just think there's more we need
more vader doing other stuff i don't we
don't need them on tatooine right right
yeah when your mother places to make the
i wish this so this is what uh this is
my crazy
marketing i wish disney had done five
episodes
and then like last at the culmination of
last week's episode they were like
surprise next friday we're releasing a
two and a half hour kenobi movie in
theaters this has all been a lead up to
the kenobi movie we wanted to do this
was all the prequel story to the or the
prologue to the story now you get to
watch to a two-hour finale i'm here for
it yeah
but alas i'll just be home on friday
night
shaving my chest
there's a certain confidence that comes
with being properly groomed there's an
aura a vibe you can just tell by the way
they carry themselves we call this bge
big groomed energy baby
and there's only one way to get that bge
man
we'd like to introduce you to the best
and biggest ultimate hygiene bundle yet
the platinum package 4.0 which used to
be my nickname for my junk mansion
is the leader 4.0 don't read into that
too
santa meaners is the leader in the way
below the weights grooming now trust
them with the rest join the four million
men worldwide who trust manscape by
going to manscape.com for 20 off and
free shipping with the code break room
listen it's hard being a hairy beast
for me it's been a lifetime of hiding in
the shadows avoiding full moons dining
on rats and possums just to survive
that is until i started grooming with
manscape
manscape's brand new platinum 4.0
package is the biggest bundle they've
ever offered giving you bulk discounts
on manscape's top products
the manscape platinum package 4.0 is the
one-stop shop for the man who deserves
it all which is me
okay they designed this package to allow
you to fully align your entire hygiene
routine with elite products inside this
platinum package
you'll find the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
weed whacker ear and nose hair trimmer
which by god i need that oh my lord my
ears are getting crazy it's like they're
growing their own separate hair inside
of it
ultra premium body wash ultra premium
two in one shampoo and conditioner ultra
premium deodorant crop preserver
anti-chafing ball deodorant crop reviver
ball spray toner take the dead balls and
revive them with the toner okay revive
those we're losing him we're losing him
we're losing him clear
is that you doing into their balls he's
got we've found a pulse a ball pulse the
shed travel bag to hold your goods while
traveling is the last piece of this
puzzle folks give 20 off and free
shipping with the code break room at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com
and use your code break room it's
important that you use the code break
room
give us a little cash bag
unlock your big groomed energy with
manscape and remember
when you trim the hedges
the tree looks enormous
i think you change it every time
i think we can we'll tweak the metaphor
every day this week uh we also let you
guys know that new rockstars is going to
be appearing live in austin texas as
part of the rtx austin 2022 podcast
festival happening july 1st through july
3rd if you've ever wanted to see some of
your favorite new rock stars host in
person now is your chance uh and you can
save on a ticket that's right click the
link in the description and use promo
code new rockstars all one word
uh and you can get a discounted ticket
they're gonna be doing a very cool live
show jessica is going to be there the
promo photo yeah do we have the promo
there's this beautiful
photo look at that oh i missed that i
got to get that beard it's real
real
they're going to be doing a crazy live
show it's like a new thing for us we
love doing it uh it's gonna be a little
trivia a little wildness a little
audience participation interacting with
you folks that's right plus we'll be in
austin eating barbecue everyone's gonna
smell great it's gonna be great
everything's bigger in texas
yeah tons of meat sweats live on stage
austin texas july 1st to the 3rd click
the link in the description use promo
code new rockstars we really hope to see
you guys there right rtx austin 2022
austin 3 16 says i just
whipped your panel at rtx
oh speaking of whipping panels mandatory
fun is now oh baby
that's right the segment's so nice we
play the graphic one time while john is
still out here
come on do it for john all right for
john one more time
beautiful yeah i revived him you better
know daschle's perfectly fine with this
job he's wonderful he's a strong man i
know he can i just don't want to you
know put too much pressure play it a
third time oh my god oh he was so ready
all right he was ready this time but
whoever knows what it's going to come
play it again oh my gosh
all right okay so he's pretty on it but
play new york for
[Applause]
uh what are we doing i forgot mandatory
we're just gonna roast whoever is
helping us
thanks for all your help play it again
we drive them away one yeah episode at a
time all right listen i know
times are tough
but you know where things are going
great
where sony had a press conference where
they invited aaron taylor johnson aka
craven the hunter to talk about his
other film bullet train with
brad pitt but you know the nerds are
never quiet the nerds can never stay
buried they got up there and asked some
craving questions and i gotta say the
answers were simply play the graphic
again
come by oh he's ready he's so big he's
so good all right
the answers were kind of he gave a very
interesting answer so the craving the
hunter is a it's rat filming
b
it was filmed almost entirely on
location which is kind of cool
does that mean like new york city or the
woods i would guess new york city or a
city standing in for new york okay
but i don't know vancouver
toronto uh anyway uh and what he also
said was that the story the character of
craven the hunter is an interesting
character because he's an animal lover
and a conservative like a conservative
of the environment really kind of
painting and twisting this like
kind of like a kinder crave in the
hunter more of a heroic thing which got
me thinking uh i didn't tell you guys
this but
i recently took on another career oh
yeah uh yeah as a uh as a as a
combination life coach
pr person
what i'm doing is i'm helping
rehabilitate some images okay there's
been some people in the news and frankly
there's been some people in this office
that have needed a little bit of a
scrubbing if you know what i mean
i don't want to point any fingers but uh
anyway uh in this time of starting a new
career i've been wildly successful we're
called uh
slap jack uh pr and then we're called uh
universal truths life coaching uh and
it's uh you can look us up we're on
swank which is uh the scandinavian
social media that we've been on uh that
a lot of my products are on now i asked
you two to help me rehabilitate a few
villain images that's right uh and you
guys each said you had something to
bring uh to me and then i also have one
would you like me to go first or would
you like to does anyone want to go i
don't mind going first but also if you
want to i don't need to go first so i
have a client okay to bring to you great
and you guys might know him as
beetlejuice yes yes beetlejuice the
infamous beetlejuice the demon that uh
attacks people at your house that's what
the image of him used to be yeah yeah i
said his name three times and he
terrorized me well well you broke his
only rule yeah and he still technically
terrorizing people let me let me pitch
you this first oh okay are you tired of
your rent skyrocketing yes the rent's
too damn high the rent is way too high
are you tired of cultivating this
perfect neighborhood just to have a
bunch of ritzy tits and people come in
and flip it upside down
yeah well then you should hire yourself
a beetlejuice he'll come to those houses
and scare the people out of those houses
no more gentrification
no more flipping houses no more rent
sky-high the rent will go down because
nobody wants to move to a neighborhood
where a demon ghost is possessing it
yeah yeah so this beetlejuice is here
for you guys now and he's only working
for people that make below eighty
thousand dollars a year if you make over
80 000 your beetlejuice isn't working
for you he's trying to scare you but if
you are poor like me
he's coming and he's going to lower your
rent that's beautiful like that yeah
yeah i you know i think that's kind of
beautiful we'll take the case yeah
daschle did you hear him he's taking a
look at me and daschle both came up with
us more so daschle he helped me a lot
all right brandon yeah i've got a client
for you i think it would be perfect okay
he's he's a man and he's obsessed with
his appearance right he wants to be a
muscular boy a strong boy a strong man
and he thinks that everyone should have
the power
of a positive image
and the power to lift up a car over
their head and throw it at someone he's
not opposed to using science to get
there okay we all can't do it naturally
no some of us aren't designed to have
big muscular bodies that's why the
doctor says i'll never be muscular
i just can't do it physically but my
body won't allow it
i could get you there without steroids
you'd let me
experiment oh well i'll consider it but
my client he wants to give you your city
back you know what i'm talking about
okay he wants to show up he he doesn't
like professional football he thinks
it's problematic and he would like to
tear down the stadiums that are usually
paid for by the time yeah
that are usually taking up valuable city
land that could be used for a public
park used for anything else oh yeah
instead of these these nfl teams holding
us hostage with will they won't they
leave our towns and the taxpayers are
praying for their stadium okay he's
tired of that he's tired of those big
wigs in wall street always work your
money okay my man
bane wants to make life a little better
for everyone he wants to put a fitness
program back into the schools get
everyone hopped up on the juice you're
feeling great well is he forcing us to
get home he's not forcing you but
it would be great if you could walk out
a little bit more don't do that voice
because i am obsessed he was born in the
mask ladies and gentlemen he was born in
the match do we have to go in the hole
uh you don't have to go in the hole
uh no
i'm already in but i'm also very
attracted to you yeah you're already
outside
well done you tell bane that he is
on the roster
he'll be so happy
he'll be holding his chest like this
i guess for mine i was hoping you guys
would help me because i i've got this
real son of a [ __ ]
i've got this uh this guy who is i'll be
honest this situation is a real [ __ ]
nightmare oh boy it's tommy using his
sweatshirt that he earned i i am thank
you again to all you super chatters
especially jones getting us over the
line yes thank you thank you uh here's
the problem with my guy it's not his
fault
he is someone who requires a warm
climate
so
around what no keep going i'm trying to
guess
he he someone requires a warm climate
just to keep himself feeling good okay
he has accumulated through hard work and
through elbow grease a pretty decent
amount of money and a really really nice
place to live is this satan
it's not safe
but that's a great guess
uh this guy requires and this is gonna
make him sound a lot more like saying
a moat of lava around a lot of his
property and lava within the castle but
that's to heat the rocks
that help him to feel good now here's
the other thing about this guy
he's got a lot of kids some his own some
adopted oh okay
each one he has given his last name to
uh or his or her or a variation on his
name to
to make them feel like they are that he
is their real father he steps up he's
not just the dad assigned at birth he's
the dad who shows his worth you know
what i'm saying this sounds like satan
it sounds like george foreman always
here's mine who is also safe
here's my problem
this guy gets solicitors at his door all
the time he's got these two italian guys
that always want to come in and check oh
my god they come in
and they wanna they go oh you plummet
let us come in also
he's in a rocky relationship i'm not
gonna lie the tablets are all over him
right now okay yeah him and his on-again
off-again girlfriend she says she feels
like a prisoner in his house and then
these italian guys are like oh we're
coming fixing a pipe and they're taking
a girlfriend and he's like you know what
let me just live a little bit and i
gotta be honest
i think i can make bowser great again
how would you think this was george
foreman well he's got a lot of kids they
take his last name they take his first
name you know
he puts all those uh those foreman
grills around his house and becomes hot
lava you know what i mean oh my god it
could have been george foreman i'll be
one of the chat guest bowser way before
we yeah
that one took me by surprise i thought
it was darth vader there for a second
with the lava guys i mean i wasn't
trying to trick you i just i feel so
impassioned i've taken on this new
career this new agency money's rolling
in you know
swank is paying me under the table and
above the table and i want to kick back
to you guys i want your help i thank you
so much for helping me today play the
graphic again
the chat
no the chat also had some great
suggestions of some some villains who
could use a little redemptive art right
uh maria cardona saying freddie cougar
yeah
he was my best friend when i was three
or four years old because there was a
pull string doll for some reason at my
house and i called him chevy i think
freddy krueger would be great for um
helping kids that study late nights in
college yeah he's trying to wake up make
sure you don't over sleep for school
he's your alarm clock yeah he's showing
you that dreams can be dangerous yes oh
my gosh i'll just live in a dream world
fragile has a great point and we always
thank figaro anyway for all of our hard
work moderating this demonic chat of
trash bags but electro he gives
electricity to people for free and we
assume clean electric i
am 100 sure that electro would
especially if it's our electro he
absolutely would be like yeah i'm gonna
go yeah
i mean td jones had a great one poison
ivy would be the greatest superheroes i
feel the world reforest things her whole
thing is like hey feed the people
growing giant coins
she's a sort of green uh really good
naked hd xyx which i believe is a
spambot says f tinder we are cheaper and
fast
great welcome straight for that spam
welcome to the chatbot
i'm a plenty of fish girl i refuse we
appealed uh we'd appeal to all bots out
i'm a christian mingleman
because i'd like to mingle with guy's
name chris oh okay hello
i knew you were gonna say something like
that after you pitch satan that's the
end of mandatory fun tommy you won
mandatory fun according to well
there are no winners in mandatory fun
only survivors now
only survivor uh
it's actually time for break room
breakdown but things are gonna happen a
little differently yeah yeah we uh we
have a video coming out on our channel
later by the
way
it might be up by now now by the by the
by the maestro
by the maestro of the move the mcu
eric voss uh and it's all about this new
tour
thor teaser trailer that we that we got
but uh
because the video didn't come out in
time for me to write some really great
questions
we're gonna just react to the trailer
and give our thoughts on it and then
we'll react and we want your guys
reactions too so uh we're gonna play the
trailer now
people use possibilities
get the popcorn out he's gonna do a
speech
see what's happening here
you're afraid
i'm scared oh oh no
anxious
my friends
times like this we need to unite come
together
i'm sorry me it's very hard to get a
rousing speech with the hate noise
oh god we're gonna die
[Applause]
this is my vowel
oh god she will die
that seems a bit dangerous
this ends here and now
marvel studios thor love and thunder
pg-13 tickets on sale now how exciting
i
i'm gonna buy you a pillow of it i want
to see more which maybe we just gotta
wait until it comes on theaters i wanna
see more of at new asgard because i
think that's where they're at where we
just saw me dressed up in the little
swoo
i'm not i hate bugs but meek he gets a
pack you think he's a bug yeah he's a
giant bug he thinks he's a little buggy
he looks like a little caterpillar uh i
i like that they replaced the swords
with little
marker yes he didn't have the sword
hands he's got the little
someone maria in the chat said meek my
child
that's how i feel uh
i definitely feel more confident that
valkyrie is gonna be killed by
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're watching
no no no no no no that's my girl sorry
if you're watching call jessica thank
you because i'm not interested do you
like women that are five seven tessa
thompson because you like men
for me it's for me i'm just copying the
bit from the yesterday okay fine keep it
to yourself
you guys when i'm at that premiere i'm
gonna oh there he goes again jesus okay
so anyways the the reaction the reaction
to this trailer they love you on camera
four my mic is off
my mic oh or our mics off
i don't know my mic can you hear me now
dashiell can you hear him
do you hear what
oh
well while tommy gets his mic
let's talk about this trailer right uh a
lot of cool new things in it you know it
was cool seeing uh more of like thor
like attacking his way through the greek
gods i don't know
it well
it's i'm so it's leaning more and more
to the idea that
thor's just showing up very late thor's
showing up very late everyone has
already been stationed in their own
areas and he's just like i think the
guardians have just kicked him out of
their group they're like you're too much
and he's like fine i'll go back home to
new asgard and everyone's like we
already started another life what is it
like thor wants to retire or whatever
but as soon as he does and he sees
people moving on he's like no no no i i
want to be a part of this still no i'm
so you're a god of thunder please
definitely him please don't let make me
retire i i don't like getting just
walking around checking out the space
i've talked to brandon about this and i
love this job more than anything my
least favorite part of this job is how i
have to watch every trailer that comes
out
i have to watch every trailer that comes
out and then we have to like
dissect it
and so now i'm like i feel like i've
seen every fight scene and i don't want
to miss the fight but there's still like
a lot that they're obviously not showing
you know they uh
uh there's gonna be a lot of movie left
and they do a good job of usually not
showing things from the third act as
much
uh and doing that those kind of things i
don't know if you saw there was another
video that came out today uh that was
kind of like a behind the scenes
making of the movie a quick little like
promo where they had some new clips in
it too but they also had a lot of like
uh the cast and crew like shooting
things and like taika
taika at one point was dressed in a suit
that almost looked like he was gonna be
in the easily the council meeting uh
that like valkyrie's having i wonder if
that he's gonna be a representative from
a country or something like that like or
playing himself in a weird way he
already plays korg in the movie true uh
so i don't know like uh i love korg he's
one of my favorites i love him so i'm
glad to see him getting so much playing
i don't want valkyrie to die
but i could also see korg and me dying
along the way oh no
they'll hear me now am i back they fake
killed meek so many times yeah
that's true yeah that is true when meek
was like yeah he's like oh he's alive
and then he was actually alive
um i yeah i don't want
it's hard because it's like for
storytelling
purposes i'm like yeah you can kill
valkyrie and it will make for good
storytelling still
uh but i just i can't i can't and i
don't want it i know it just seems like
they're showing that like her in an epic
battle with gore right do we know if it
could have been like a flashback
possibly ooh
maybe i didn't see gore if he was all
scarred up or yeah i think he's like
black and white they're all scarred up
uh i mean i think he's gonna be such a
compelling villain i know they've like
teased that a lot like that's how it's
gonna be but he really does look insane
and looks great
uh and i'm very interested to see what
he's been up to and how long he's been
up to it for cause that's my thing too
yeah has he just been killing for a week
has this been going on for years and no
one's noticed well that's the thing with
the the thing of it
like when someone said it was like a
detective noir
it's like well that implies that the
crimes have been happening recently
right right like it's like that means
that
i don't know when you say dark noir what
i think okay so we're seeing that black
and white planet
didn't we talk about something somewhere
along the lines that like as he's
killing people that's when the color
starts coming yeah this idea that he has
like so much darkness that he's like
absorbing the light like killing the
gods to provide the light or something
like that like he's
taking it all away those parts could be
the noir like kind of [ __ ]
um
what is it uh detective part it could
also be like the power of like the necro
sword right it could be absorbing all
the light because it's part of uh it's
symbiote history someone's which they
might not get into
jane attacking people with pieces of
muller can she control the pieces
individually yes there's that weird move
that's been in the trailer where she's
like swinging it
inside of uh it looks like inside of the
the god zone or whatever and like
something shoots out of it
uh
like a spread uh but it still looks like
the hammer's intact yeah i wonder if
it's just like chunks of electricity i
think she can put it back together and i
think she is the one that put it back
together we theorized this scenario so
many times but i'll say it again i think
that a lot of people on the planet is
worthy but she's the one that came in
contact with it anyway and zip back
together because it's not like healed
either yeah it's still in peace it's
still like
it's not like re-welded right so you can
still see all the cracks i mean that
would be cool if she could like
you know make it expand into little
pieces and then come back together
around someone's head or something like
that
and just like crushes behind outside
yeah behind them and pulls it back
through them you make someone eat every
piece of meat
does stormbreaker grant thor different
weather appropriate attire because he
has like a new everyone's got new
outfits right uh that's something we've
kind of talked about is that something
that the other gods are giving them
to power them up
yeah
you didn't mention that well i just
think he's finally changing uh if we are
going through the timeline of him
partying with uh the guardians of the
galaxy guardians galaxy kicks him out
he's going to new asgard we saw meek and
korg like or meek at least in a suit
teaching and then we see um
valkyrie also dressed up in a suit like
doing something i think he's just
changing his outfits to be appropriate
with where they're at
i like that that's respectful i would
like it if you know
when when thor's going to his little
mountainside to meditate or whatever
the ghost of odin shows up and like
gives him a little bit of a odin force
and changes his outfit and makes it all
gold
and he's like and ghost odin is like you
gotta go get that mf for zeus he's
always doing me dirty he's always been
going after frigga i want you to go kill
zeus
you're the god butcher now kill him yeah
you're the god butcher now no that would
be a fun side mission
to kill kill zoos yeah
do you guys think there's any chance
loki's in this movie uh on the tattoo on
his back we we i like we kind of empty
and i talked about that in a bq where
we're kind of like tracking where
everyone is as we lead into this movie i
think if there is a loki cameo in this
movie i just want it to be loki
checking in opening like a time door
seeing that thor is okay and it's like
okay i'm out like i i don't think i
don't think thor could handle seeing
loki again after he's watched him die so
many times and then he was actually dead
the last time i think it would be really
heavy for him and i don't know it would
it would really change the pace of the
movie yeah i agree i agree we're going
to show you but i would like to see loki
be sweet and check in on yeah
but this is also a different this is a
different loki he's younger and he's
also truly uh i'd be like
my brother can handle that dear god
slayer i have to deal with king the
conqueror it's also been only like five
years for
five or six years for thor and they live
for thousands of years so it's like not
much time has passed it's his brother
who's attacking them in the citadel
well i still think it's like thor
sneaking in and they start attacking
thor i think but it does seem like
no keep going it does seem like jane's
fighting in there too at some point i
think i we talked about this before and
i stand by it i think they're doing a
gladiator scenario where russell crowe
is now
joaquin phoenix and he's making them
fight in the arena and it's like the
same thing with um jeff goldblum and
thor ragnarok where he's not taking it
seriously right where he's like i have
somewhere to go and he's like
well i'm the god zeus so where do you
have to be that's more important than
here and he's like fight
i think that's why they're doing it
because i also think they could have got
anyone
i think they could have got anyone to
play zeus but i think it's fun to make
it wrestle crow because it's going to be
a gladiator scenario
yeah that could that could be a lot of
fun i also think it could be
zeus being like all right who's the most
worthy here
is that you or is it jamie's name i'm
like both fighting that makes sense
it's because it's like it's also like
he's not they're not doing anything no
one around them is like oh no this guard
is going crazy and running away they're
just they're sitting there watching him
fight that's for sure what they don't
seem like gore's minions thor's fully
clothed and jane vacary korg are
fighting with them one hundred percent i
agree is raven
ravinger jacket just star lords old one
from guardians of the galaxy vol 2 i
mean he definitely just stole it jackie
he ripped the sleeves off
and was like this is happening could he
fit in it that's the thing his arms
don't fit his arms that's why i remember
my god do his arms not fit holy cannoli
uh we had some other super chats we
should shout out shout out as we around
the corner on this episode of the break
room uh bee leaf
bee leaf 789 saying shout outs to mads
and dior my mcu watch party homies yeah
it's always good to have a good mcu
watch party we we try and go and see the
movies as a as a company when we can go
see them when you guys are seeing it i'm
max i will join you but you guys some
people get to go earlier to see the film
so you know that's how it works out
sometimes i'm also a great husband and i
go see them none of my friends watch any
of the marvel movies and it's
like it is
the pain in my life my friends will only
go see the marvel plays
i can do this all okay
i love a marvel play uh salvador
laurette farina send in a super chat
saying uh it's going back to our obi-wan
discussion so riva as one of vader's
secret apprentices a allah starkiller
slash proto-lumia
doesn't appeal as a season two plot i
don't know if they'll do a season two of
this show
i think i want a poll in the chat do we
want a season two of kenobi yeah quick
and short i would rather have the like
vader show and just go show vader be a
jerk across the galaxy i'd rather have
that that's the problem with having
vader and obi-wan together is we'll
never get that resolution in this show
that's why where's that dolph darth maul
story we were gonna have you know what i
mean come on give me that give me that
darth maul give me that door half man
half machine give me that mo
give me that crystal
um uh mike also had a super chat
regarding obi-wan what if obi-wan stays
in tatooine because he knows there's
former pandawans out there dedicating
their lives to protect children cal
ahsoka riva etc uh i mean we know
obi-wan will stay on tatooine he seems
to chill out there uh
but
i don't know he did somewhat more jedi
coming there for sure that that really
spoils the game it would be funny if
they just keep showing up because they
hear he's there you have to like shoo
i think there's universal things that we
all have in common and i think one big
thing we have in common is stop going to
tatooine so please stop doing the shows
on tatooine i've seen enough attacks
it's a universal thing that it's if
you're that person that's like give me
more tattooine
my dude
oh my dude um we also write a poem in
the chat do you think korg will die in
four four oh 74 no yeah that's us like
dreaming big and really hopefully he
doesn't die he dies i don't think he
gets to kill him
don't do it uh max savage also sending
in a super chat thank you so much max do
we think gore will be alive when it's
all over does gore survive thor four so
we have more gore gorge of gor gore more
gorge good gore four more
i can put you in a nice four-door
gorford was there a gore before the gorf
i you have to ask me beyond the fjord
there's ford selling gore ford sportor
but not anymore if you open the door you
can read the lure of more gore and thor
oh this is melting my brain um
it's unfortunate because the gore to me
is like doctor doom where i'm like i was
so excited to see him and i don't want
him to be washed away with just one
movie yeah i know it seems like it's
gonna be very cool but i don't know how
you can leave this sucker over i mean
they do they did it with well we don't
know if task master is dead but like
same diff of like oh we're so excited
and maybe that was all we're going to
see if taskmaster it might be same with
gore um i think that uh
no one ever really died
no one ever top out answer uh
uh well thank you guys so much for
joining us today we asked you in the
chat you guys want to see vader series
more than a kenobi season two i think we
can all agree absolutely big finale
tonight we'll stay up late we'll watch a
little kenobi uh we'll also watch miss
marvel we're gonna get episodes and then
get up early with me and aircross to do
wikileaks uh yeah we'll have wikileaks
we'll have inside marvel tomorrow uh
umbrella academy comes out tonight as
well we'll have boys later in the week
tomorrow's going to be a crazy show
definitely watch kenobi
we might save our miss marvel convos for
thursday
tomorrow will probably be the kenobi
fallouts and how we live on our lives
with that uh thank you so much for
joining us today hit that like button i
know it it it's wrote to ask that hit
the like button hit the like button we
like it when you hit the like button uh
we enjoy all of you we appreciate all of
you all you breakers all your roomies
all you super trash we love you have a
great rest of your tuesday see you later
happy summer solstice put an egg on your
table and stand it up straight what it's
the summer solstice
put an egg on your head